elles font 35 cm et honte avec des
moteurs de chevaux ces petites voitures
radiocommandées sont très équipée elle
concourt tu as une compétition régionale
c'est une course 80 pilotes et ça va se
dérouler sur la journée ça a commencé ce
matin à 8 heures jusqu'à 18h ce soir
ce matin c'est les qualifications et
dans l'après midi on va faire les
remontées jusqu'à la finale qui aura
lieu vers 17h30 18h le club de modélisme
de maurepas va fêter cette année ses 50
ans cent trente adhérents le composent
sur trois catégories différentes
la voiture électrique le slot reis et la
voiture thermique
cette dernière fait l'objet de notre
compétition du jour pour laquelle les
pilotes viennent de toute la france
le club est super sympa donc qui
retrouve également l'ambiance avec tous
les tous les potes avec lesquels on
roule alors général au club sur le stand
de préparation entre deux courses les
pilotes aussi mécanicien bichonnent
leurs bolides
j'ai encore de changer ma batterie parce
que là j'ai roulé pour 20 minutes donc
déjà j'ai ma batterie une passion qui se
transmet ici de père en fils les plus
petits entre en piste au milieu des
grands
ce que j'aime vers les voitures et quand
j'ai vu on va pas faire ça m'a donné
envie de faire
le jeune mathis prometteur a remporté la
compétition dans sa catégorie
prochain rendez vous pour le club ce
samedi 25 mai pour une course du vintage
en intérieur